alors je pas si vous voyez j'ai
privilège de pouvoir m'asseoir par
rapport aux autres intervenants
voilà donc je suis plus à l'aise à six
parce que bon je suis pas très habitué à
parler en public
alors moi je suis là ce soir c'est pour
vous dire que l'amour est une énergie
une force qui vient d'ailleurs et ça je
l' ai appris à la dure parce que le
début de ma vie jusqu'à 30 ans et est
basée sur un contrat du est ce que je
peux vous dire c'est que le contrat du
pivot le passé avec vous même mais du
coup vous le passé avec les autres aussi
et ça va coûter cher ça m'a coûté très
cher apportant tous les signaux de la
vie je les ai eues mais je ne les ai pas
vus j'ai perdu mon père n'est pas 50 ans
j'ai perdu ma soeur dans le crash du
mont sainte odile et dans la foulée je
me savard est ma compagne et qui est
aussi la mère de ma fille bref j'étais
dévastée mais je tombé dans les bras de
la première femme qui allait pouvoir
m'aider à satisfaire mes besoins de
l'ambition et je rêvais de l'épousé je
rêvais de l'épousé parce que je rêvais
d'épouser ce qu'elle représentait pour
moi elle représentait la réussite
sociale est représentée l'intégration
dans une grande famille et puis elle
était belle les autres aussi le voulait
et puis moi je l'avais donc moi j'étais
à j'étais fier à pourquoi j'ai fait tout
ça pour quoi j'ai fait ce contrat de pub
parce que je croyais que c'était ça
l'amour moi je pensais que l'amour ça
faisait partie du décor alors inutile de
vous dire que ce contrat dupes a cessé
brutalement et dimanche matin pour des
petits pains malcuit moi je vivais la
deuxième séparation de la vie et puis au
lieu de me poser des questions sur cette
situation je reprenais le cours de ma
vie comme si de rien n'était sur les
routes de l'ambition alors comme souvent
dans pareil cas c'est la vie qui est
calé me faire changer de cap avec une
violence inouïe
deux mois après après ma séparation je
suis terrassé par une hémorragie
cérébrale
et là d'un seul coup d'un seul
ma vie tombe dans l'incertitude je suis
entre la vie et la mort pendant 14 jours
et je sort du coma dans lequel j'étais
plongé en constatant que j'avais été
opéré du cerveau que je ne parlait plus
j'étais paralysé demont côté droit et
que je n'avais plus de mémoire que je
sais que ma vie était finie le
chirurgien qui m'a opéré
j'aime voir en me disant que la
situation est grave mais séquelles
irréversibles mais que j'étais jeune les
battants et justement j'étais jeune et
j'ai j'avais envie de faire autre chose
de ma vie
mettez vous à ma place vous auriez fait
quoi si du jour au lendemain on vous
annonce que vous ne pouvais plus marcher
vous ne pouvez plus parler je n'ai plus
de mémoire vous crient à l'injustice
vous êtes révolter 1 contrairement à
toussaint j'étais dans le lâcher prise
totale je me suis senti soulagé et la
vie m'avait coupé la tête et les jambes
mais mon être intérieur était restée
intacte et c'est mon refuge
c'est mon refuge je me reconnecte à
moins et cette connexion va me permettre
de soigner mes blessures avec amour et
indulgence vis-à-vis de moi-même et
vis-à-vis de la vie j'ai même de la
gratitude car je suis encore vivant
miraculeusement est soulagé de mes
tensions
j'apprends à relativiser la situation ce
qui me permet d'appréhender ce combat
avec force et courage et sa 7,6 m'a
permis de passer les trois années de
spécialisation en apprenant ce que
voulait dire la patience et le
renoncement est sorti de cette épreuve
g j'ai une autre relation avec la vie
j'ai entrepris un dialogue interne avec
moi même pour me guérir
donc je me faisais des demandes comme on
fait des prières et la miraculeusement
j'ai retrouvé la parole j'ai retrouvé la
mémoire et j'ai retrouvé mes fonctions
cérébrales et j'ai retrouvé la mobilité
nécessaire pour pouvoir être indépendant
et plus pour être là ce soir
g monsieur accompli en tant qu'homme
parce que j'ai compris que être en
accord avec soi-même
7 c'est donner sens à son existence être
en accord avec soi même et donc
forcément j'ai compris qu'en faisant des
demandes je pouvais changer un petit peu
le cours de mon existence
et donc j'ai élargi mes demandes j'ai
compris qu'il fallait que je j'écoute ça
que je suis toujours mon guide
intérieure et je me suis découvert un
qu'un pouvoir un pouvoir exceptionnel un
pouvoir extraordinaire que j'avais en
moi et leur départ j'étais convaincue
d'avoir ce pouvoir
suite à mon traumatisme suite à mon
commun et puis c'est qu'elle par la
suite bien longtemps après que je me
suis rendu compte que ce pouvoir était
universel c'est un pouvoir magique que
nous poussait dans tous ces le pouvoir
d'attraction qui peut faire venir à soi
ce qu'on désire réellement à partir du
moment où on formule une demande avec
sincérité et par rapport à ses
aspirations profondes
donc il est possible en effet de faire
venir à soi l'amour et c'est pour ça que
je suis là ce soir pour vous dire
comment vous pouvez formuler simplement
et clairement une demande dans ce sens
et je vous dire comment j'ai fait venir
à moi
la femme de ma vie celle qui partage ma
vie en restant simplement et
tranquillement chez moi l'attend pas
besoin de connexion internet
alors je suis désolé pour mon
prédécesseur pas besoin d'applications
type à peine
pas besoin de sites de rencontres non
plus la seule connexion à avoir pour y
parvenir c'est la collection à soi même
être en connexion avec son être
intérieur va vous permettre de formuler
des demandes
elle attirait à vous la personne que
vous désirez réellement
alors moi j'ai réalisé cette demande
celle de rencontrer la femme avec qui je
vis un moment donné où j'étais un
tourment de madame l'existence j'étais
célibataire depuis quelques années et
puis j'ai spirent est réellement a
rencontré la femme qu'ils allaient
partager le restant de ma vie donc j'ai
cherché à m'engager dans une relation
amoureuse durable tant que je devais
être précis dans ma demande et made man
se résumer comme suit et je vous les
livre comme ça j'aimerais rencontrer une
femme avec qui je m'engage avec qui je
m'engagerai pour la vie alors sorti de
son contexte mafra dallaire un petit peu
romantique un petit peu bateau mais pour
moi elle a une importance capitale j'ai
48 ans et j'ai clairement pas envie de
perdre mon temps j'ai envie de m'engager
avec ma partenaire de vie et donc pour
ne pas me tromper pour être sûr de la
reconnaître parce qu'il ya véritable
enjeu je décide de mettre en harker leur
jeu je pense à mon chirurgien qui m'a
opéré sauvé la vie quelques années
auparavant
il se prénomme l'ol argy tient bien
nommé alors je décide de préciser ma
demande de la manière suivante
j'aimerais rencontrer une femme avec qui
je m'engagerai pour la vie et pour être
sûr de la reconnaître
j'aimerais qu'elle soit née à l'ol voilà
c'est bien facile
si on croit au père noël et puis y'a
qu'à faire la demande et puis on verra
bien alors si je suis là ce soir c'est
parce que vous en doutez vous en doutez
bien mais demande a réussi je vous
expliquerai comment j'ai réussi à faire
venir une femme avec qui je m'engage et
kiên à noël alors le tout quand on fait
cette demande c'est de faire une demande
elle l'a lancé comme ça parce qu'on
collabore avec l'univers donc on
collabore avec les phares de la vie donc
moi j'ai fait une demande d g vaquer à
mes occupations et donc pour être tout à
fait honnête avec vous
j'y pensais plus vraiment donc les mois
passent les semaines passent et les mois
passent et je me retrouve à quelques
jours de noël et j'ai un message sur mon
répondeur répondeur automatique d'une
personne que je ne connais pas qui me
dit avoir vu une dédicace que je faisais
pour un livre que j'avais sorti et qui
regrettaient de ne pas pouvoir avoir été
assez dédicacé qui me demande s'il était
possible d'en avoir quatre exemplaires
pour noël est là et immédiatement quand
j'entends le son de sa voix tout de
suite mon petit vol intérieur me dis
attention là la femme que tu viens
d'avoir au téléphone il faut la voir il
faut la rencontre et s'est complètement
irrationnel mais par contre je la
rencontre alors ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est quand on fait la demande il n'y a
pas de critères liés au physique à l'âge
aux revenus comme on peut le faire sur
internet ont fait confiance à la vie ont
fait confiance parce qu'on est dans le
lâcher prise
on n'est pas dans le mental est donc je
décide de la rappeler et de lui proposer
sans la connaître de lui livrer
directement les livres et je lui propose
un rendez vous ici à strasbourg au bar
du sofitel et donc rendez vous est pris
j'arrive au sofitel avec cette intuition
d'avoir un rendez vous avec mon destin
et quand j'arrive au bar du sofitel je
ne sais pas à quoi va ressembler cette
femme est la surprise à l'entrée
dubard j'aperçois une femme magnifique
très belle je sais peut pas être elle
est trop belle est trop trop trop belle
femme et quand je la vois
elle me sourit et se dirige vers moi et
là j'ai inclus foule geste incroyable
quand même on prend un verre on échange
lui livre mes livres on discute de nos
vies on se trouve des tacots incidence
extraordinaire par rapport à nos vies
par rapport à mon livre un mot
l'histoire et le temps passe deux heures
passées puis on se quitte à regret et en
partant là cette phrase extraordinaire
elle me dit ceci ce trésor est très
touché que vous m'ayez livrer ses livres
en main propre parce qu'ils vont être
sous le sapin de noël et pour moi noël
un double signification
noël c'est bien sûr la fête de noël
mais c'est également le jour de mon
anniversaire là je peux vous dire que
cette extraordinaire mais il faut faire
attention parce que moi j'ai envie
d'embrasser j'ai envie de la prendre
dans mes bras je dis ouais je voulais je
t'ai trouvée mais je la connais pas
cette femme je la connais que le puits
deux heures et donc là je dis attention
calme-toi elle n'est pas au courant elle
est décalée par rapport à toi
tu peux pas l'embrasser et dans toute la
difficulté pour moi c'est eux c'est de
dire ok prend le plaisir d'attendre les
quelques jours les quelques heures
jusqu'à ce que tu es vraiment cette
femme dans ta vie et donc je pars
heureux
là j'y viens de donner le plus beau des
cadeaux de noël est donc forcément je
suis impatient de la revoir
on se revoit plusieurs fois entre noël
et nouvel an on se comprend un verre on
apprend à discuter enfin on apprend à se
connaître on discute ensemble et puis on
décide de passer noël en ca de passer
nouvel ensemble et comme j'ai envie de
l'embrasser mais j'ai pas envie de de
perdre cet amour j'ai cette idée
cette idée de de faire accélérer un
petit peu le processus et je lui dit
écoutez je suis très heureux de passer
les fêtes de nouvel an avec vous
est ce que je vous propose c'est la
chose suivante sur le coup de minuit
je propose trois alternatives
je vous embrasse sur la joue ça veut
dire que je vous aime bien et que je
suis content de passer ce moment avec
vous je vous embrasse au coin de la
bouche
ça veut dire que je suis hésitant et que
j'aimerais bien mais je ne suis pas sûr
et si je vous embrasse à pleine bouche
on passe au moins l'année ensemble sinon
la vie ensemble et je peux vous dire que
son coup de minuit c'est pas moi qui les
embrasser à pleine bouche c'est take him
embrasser à pleine bouche est donc
aujourd'hui si vous voulez je vais vous
dire que des histoires d'amour ça existe
à ce que l'amour c'est une énergie
c'est une force qui vient pas d'ailleurs
mais une force qui vient de l'intérieur
mais si on reste connectés à soi même et
si on collabore avec l'univers on peut
faire venir à soi l'amour qu'on désire
réellement et qui nous correspond
véritablement alors aujourd'hui on est à
deux mois son anniversaire puisque son
adversaire et c'est le 24 décembre et
j'ai écrit et composé une musique
pour elle pour cette rencontre qu'on a
eu et pour nous tous aussi parce que
c'est une chanson d'amour et le titre
c'est vanessa puisque son prénom c'est
vanessa je vais je vais parce que je
vais mieux en étant amoureux en ayant
trouvé la femme qui partage ma vie est
donc ce soir l'anefa je t'invite à
découvrir ce clip que je te dédie voilà
et de regards de visite
g
les fleurs de jasmin
ils se trompent a ajouté
2 6
et
monsieur d
c'était parole
et d
des jeux
les sentiments
je
je vais je
j -ph
le
le leader
ce que
che
des souris
l'instantané
te
j'ai fait
j
m
monsieur
je
été soutenue
st
g
et puis tout ça
je sais je sais
je veux
si j'avais trop
on est super